It's the charming, hilarious Ben Schwartz!
Everybody's so...
You can feel how kind,
everybody's so nice and ready to applaud and be,
look, everybody's going like this, you can't see it.
You have an incredible crowd.
Well, they're just so excited to see you
because "Sonic 2" had the biggest box office opening ever
for a video game turned movie.
Whoa!
What a transition.
Wow.
I used to play Sega.
Were you a big Sega fan?
So I had a Super Nintendo and David Fernandez,
'cause you never could have both.
No.
David Fernandez had a Genesis.
So I'd play at his house Sonic
and then at my house, it would be Super Nintendo games.
Now fast forward and you're in the movie.
It's crazy.
Did you feel that pressure?
Should I be here in a swivel?
Yeah, that's good.
That's why it is a swivel.
I don't wanna be rude, and over the shoulder it.
Although it's so striking over the shoulder.
Ask me a quick question, Drew.
Ben, how are you today?
Very good, thank you.
(Drew laughs)
I think I should lead with my head and then follow.
I like it.
That's what I'll do, I'll lead with my head
and then follow.
I think that's smart.
So I'm not trying to be rude to anybody.
But yes, the opening weekend is very exciting.
And also, so I've never been in a movie
of this stature before and they give you all these numbers.
Another number they said
is it's Jim Carrey's biggest domestic opening weekend ever,
which is crazy because he's like the king.
And there you are with him.
Yeah.
Well, I have letters, 'cause the last time you were on,
we talked about,
I do a segment here on this show called Dear Drew,
which, we do a zip code of the day.
And sometimes in this modern world,
I wanna drop a technological mic
and beam people in Star Trek style.
But I also wanna harken back to the gentleness
of the television that we all grew up on.
and I love snail mail
and you came on,
and we discovered this about each other and became pen pals.
Yeah, I have typewriters.
The reason why I love typewriters
is you can use them the same exact way
you used them 70 years ago.
I'm using the same exact device as someone did 70 years ago.
And I love writing people letters.
And I believe, Drew, it was you who got a letter from E.T.
And look, I got an ALF card too.
And he sent an ALF playing card
from the '90s as well.
I'm not getting spit on it.
Look at how cool this is.
I'm sorry, but like...
this is not a text.
I will say this, 'cause obviously you're very busy,
both of you are very busy.
I wasn't expecting a letter back.
Drew wrote me back a five page handwritten letter back.
And it was amazing.
And went into detail and put your heart into it,
and then played with the bit that you're responding to E.T.
but then also as a human being talking to a human being.
Yes.
But E.T. was very, he was on one one day.
This was him.
He was a little naughty on this day.
This is so cute.
I remember you guys saying
you were going to write each other
and you actually followed through with it.
I know, what are the odds of people
following through with things?
I don't know, but is it time for another letter?
It could be.
Continue our pen paling.
I have a feeling E.T. has a lot more to say
to Drew Barrymore.
Well, Gertie's around.
(upbeat bright music)